safeway just held their annual 47th  pumpkin weigh-in in half moon bay  california and here now is the man with  the winning  2 350 pound pumpkin travis gengar  congratulations travis look at that  pumpkin  yeah thanks for having me thank you so  much do you feel good  you called this tiger i'm sorry pumpkin  tiger king right  yeah cause it was orange with like white  stripes and white dots so yeah that's  what we named it  do you feel so proud to have the largest  pumpkin in town  yeah it was uh just pure joy and relief  you know  so congratulations on your big win that  is the biggest pumpkin i've ever seen we  have incredible pictures  and we'll put them all up on the website  it's really  impressive you can see the size and the  scale and you can see why you're the big  big winner travis  thanks congratulations to you and tiger  king pumpkin